2018 a été marquée par plusieurs fuites
de données et de failles de sécurité
est ce que nos données et informations
personnelles seront davantage en
sécurité en 2019 on va en parler avec
notre invité anne sophie le tellier qui
est chargé de cours doctorante et
directrice des communications pour
crypto québec bonjour madame l'atelier
et la hausse et 2018 ça a été fracassée
évidemment cette histoire avec cambridge
analytica du côté de facebook donc
facebook finalement qui avait en quelque
sorte donné des données personnelles
sais c'est que c'est pas ça en fait
qu'est ce qu'on s'est rendu compte avec
un bug gênant du tout cas c'est que
facebook avait donné accès à énormément
donc avait pas de donner des données
personnelles il y avait donné accès à
une facilité la chose parce que facebook
se défend bien de vendre les données de
ces de ses clients ou de ces de sa wii
de ses clients chez qui elle dit à ses
utilisateurs donc que l'on s'est rendu
compte que oui en utilisant facebook
on veut créer des données sur nous aussi
des métadonnées qu'on ne contrôle pas
nécessairement donc le temps qu'on va
regarder une publication donc plein de
choses peut-être qui échappe à
l'utilisateur et tous ceux évidemment
c'est emmagasinée et ça créé des profils
extrêmement précis et quand ces données
sont utilisées mais une fois qu'ils
existent on peut justement et les poly
vent mais les partager à des partenaires
d'affaires comme ça a été le cas
rappelons le c'est que ça a été utilisée
finalement lors de la campagne
électorale et non plus exactement puis
ça a servi aussi pour les bois existait
tout ça donc là on se dit ah bé ce qu'on
pouvait se servir avant pour faire la
publicité ciblée à belles surprises là
on est également capable de faire du
microciblage politique donc ça devient
un peu plus problématique
bon ça c'est passé un peu plus un peu
plus tôt dans l'année il ya eu un peu
plus tard avec justement ce qu'on a
appris peu plus il ya deux semaines
environ
qu'ils partageaient aussi des messages
privés des utilisateurs avec d'autres
partenaires de silicon valley donc là on
se rend compte de 1 qu'il ya une
économie au complet qui fait autour de
la récolte de nous donner donc qui ont
un travail en amont qui doit être fait
pour sécuriser tout ça mais après ça on
se dit à quel point on les partage
quelles données ont le droit de ramasser
donc c'est toutes ces questions là un
peu et que 2018
un nid dans l'air et puis je pense qu'il
faut qu'on se pose des questions
sociales
vous avez raison aussi problème de fond
est ce que c'est pas justement coordonne
toujours davantage aussi madame
l'atelier des informations des
entreprises
on perd le contrôle finalement de ses
données personnelles oui je pense qu'on
perd le contrôle puis après ça il ya une
responsabilisation un peu d entreprises
que je pense qu'il ya vraiment apte à
pouvoir récolter plus de données que
possible sur les utilisateurs parce que
c'est lucratif évidemment ça permet
aussi d'offrir de meilleurs services
mais souvent les entreprises vont pas
nécessairement mettre les efforts
qu'elle devrait pour sécuriser ces
données là donc ça va être quand même
assez problématique à cet égard là parce
que si on récolte des données
personnelles
ben il faut pouvoir les sécuriser pour
éviter des fuites
et puis ça c'est pas toujours des
pratiques qui sont qui sont lucrative ou
sinon il ya peu c'est pas insister parce
que ça coûte beaucoup plus cher avoir
une bonne pratique de sécurité en place
que d'avoir une fuite occasionnels donc
il ya pas encore les bons mécanismes
pour dissuader les entreprises texas
pour les entreprises maintenant pour
nous pauvres utilisateurs des médias
sociaux
comment on peut faire pour se protéger
on dit souvent mais je suis certain que
déjà la maison de savoie alors il ya les
mots de passe notamment
donc c'est ce que les mots de passe est
déjà voir un bonnet une bonne hygiène de
monde passe sa cabale j'adore les clubs
bonne hygiène
s'il m'a pas baver c'est quoi ces
histoires n'ont justement pas changé
souvent en avoir des sécuritaires on
s'est rendu compte que quand on change
les montre pas souvent en fait qu'est ce
qui se passe c'est que les gens vont en
avoir des moins sécuritaire en général
donc que ça il faut nécessairement la
cause donc savoir des bons mots de passe
des puits aussi que c'est une tendance
pour 2019 je pense que ça va être la fin
aussi ça va être très vulnérable d'avoir
juste un facteur d'authentification donc
juste un mot de passe pour sécuriser un
compte donc une bonne résolution à faire
pour tout le monde en 2019 je prends ça
va être d'utiliser des multiples
facteurs d'authentification donc que ce
soit à travers une clé usb à travers une
application comme google ou justement
envoyer un sms sur son téléphone à
chaque fois qu'on se connecte donc ça
c'est un double facteur donc quelque
chose qu'on connaît le mot de passe est
quelque chose que l'on a sur soi comme
ce même si le mot de passe et
vulnérabiliser personne est capable
d'avoir une intrusion 2019 gens étaient
très intéressants je chantais déjà
maison familiale
12h09 également aussi vous savez en 2018
système d'amazon alex a fait partager
aux autres est rendu compte finalement
que des données aussi avait glissé à ce
moment là oui dans le fond c'est arrivé
deux fois dans l'année dû justement une
fois aussi qu'il y avait un couple qui
avait eu une conversation et puis qu'est
la conversation avait été envoyé par
mégarde un de leurs contacts chez des
systèmes intelligents qu'on retrouve à
l'intérieur des examens qui soit aussi
vous êtes à surveiller pour la prochaine
année parce que je pense qu'il ya un
engouement qui est qu ils y assument
mais encore une fois je pense que les
compagnies à la fois qui créent ces
produits là mais aussi qu'ils stockent
les données ne met pas nécessairement
toutes les bonnes pratiques en mesure de
sécurité pour pouvoir sécuriser la
chaussée selon la tribune l avantage de
piratage en 2019
heureusement ou malheureusement oui
c'est quelque chose qui va devoir
s'améliorer puisque on peut faire un
niveau personnel et organisationnelles
mot de passe puis encouragé ces
personnes et s'est employé à ne pas
cliquer sur des liens douteux c'est les
deux vecteurs d'attaqué plus fréquente
pas écouté sont avertis à tout le moins
anne sophie le tellier doctorants
directrice des communications pour
crypter au québec
merci beaucoup d'avoir établi